Một tên thân, đại diễn đổi kánh xa tông đường bộ, các tốc số xấu của kinh xa tông bộ của Ngàn Sò biết,
đơn vị đặc trên kai biển pháp sự dụng ô tô gái chang, vi chuyển trên các tuyên cáo tốc để giận bi pháp.
Các hành vi vị phạm gồm, xuyên lần không có tí thiệu bao chiếc, dừng đổ không đúng quy định,
trải quá tốc độ, trải giữ tốc độ tối thiệu, quốc đi và lần dừng khởi cấp.
Các quả từ xấu dường em ba tháng tư đến xấu dường em một tên thư, đã kinh nhận và phát hiện chí mi tám trường ở bi pháp.
Tổng mức tiền phát dự kiến khoảng hơn năm 2018 đã là biến bản sức biếp 1.5 trường ở
mức tiền phát một trong năm mới mốt trường đông. Chào nó chuyển lần không có tính hiểu bao chiếc,
mời trường hợp dừng đổ trên đường cốc tốc khổ đúng nơi quy định hai mi trường hợp.
Dừng đổ nơi có biển cấm, tảm chừng hợp, trải quá tốc độ, hai mi chính trường hợp, trải giữ tốc độ tối thiệu,
mời bài trường hợp, trải elan dừng xe khẩn cấp bố trường hợp, vi pham khác, mời trường hợp.
Theo lực lượng chức năng, việc tăng cường giám sát nhằm bà đầm xe tự án bản sâu thông, trong mối cảnh hệ thống cao tốc phát triển nháng,
lưu lượng quân tiền lớn.